pour en parler nous sommes avec un
ghislaine pierrât docteur en
communication politique qui a écrit
plusieurs livres la communication n'est
pas un jeu que j'ai ici aux éditions
l'harmattan
emmanuel macron et les autres aux
éditions également de l'harmattan merci
d'être avec nous je lis and tiara est-ce
qu'on est clairement en train d'assister
à un tournant il y en a eu plusieurs
rames et un autre tournant à saissac
d'ailleurs comme virage dans le
quinquennal emmanuel macron selon vous
alors bon effectivement on est à un
virage je me suis même pas si c'est un
virage
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il ya une à
dix nations est une espèce de colère
hystérie collective à vous à la sur
l'image d' emmanuel macron vous on se
souvient bon de la tête sur une pique
des décos libé un peu partout donc
effectivement il se passe quelque chose
de très important
c'est sauf erreur de ma part quand même
la première fois qu'il ya une vraie
fronde à peine cachée au sein même de la
majorité qui était plutôt bon soldat par
quelques papes quelques cas apparemment
fallait y ait vraiment eu de la colère
exprimée ça nous rappelle un peu à
l'époque du quinquennat de françois
hollande va confier ces frondeurs de de
gauche de la gauche c'est ce que c'est
comparable alors le si on parle du deuil
parental on ne peut pas faire de la
politique si on n'aime pas les gens
c'est pas possible donc il ya des
députés qui se sont laissés entraîner
dans un vote qui est un vote de deux
refus par rapport à la proposition de
guy bricout le député udi a géré pendant
qui a fait une proposition de 12 jours
pour un deuil d'un enfant on sait qu'il
ya 4500 enfants qui meurent avant la
majorité en france par an c'est énorme
donc du coup on ne peut pas répondre
avec une logique comptable de
financement de la mesure
face à à à à une désespérance comme ça
des familles parce que perdre un enfant
c'est un défi à la raison
donc là les députés je suis rendu compte
que il y avait comme une espèce de
logique clinique un peu trop technocrate
un peu trop comptable et que quand ils
sont retournés dans leur circonscription
ils se sont fait houspiller par tous les
français et ils sont revenus
remontés comme des horloges parce que
ils disent c'est pas possible on ne peut
pas refuser une mesure de bon sens
généreuse tout ça parce que on dit
qu'elle est mal ficelé par ce que il
n'ya pas le financement de la mesure ça
tient pas debout
c'est une critique qui revient très
souvent ce manque entre guillemets
d'humanité du gouvernement est ce que là
on est dans l'illustration parfaite de
ce gouvernement qui peut hors sol qui
n'est pas connecté avec et vraies
préoccupations des français et et j'ai
dû m'arrêter simplement je dirais pas
que emmanuel macron manque d'humanité
parle de l'air dont vous avez vu
d'ailleurs qu emmanuel macron et
briquets en disant bon stop c'est une
boulette faut le reconnaître mais je
dirais plutôt que la communication est
extrêmement maladroite qu'on va de
maladresse en improvisation
d'improvisation en à la va-vite et du
coup c'est ça ça cafouille la meilleure
communication c'est celle qui ne se voit
pas et aujourd'hui on a des d une
succession comme ça de maladresses qui
font que ça donne à emmanuel macron un
côté technocrates l'inhumain rapide bon
et est ce que ça corresponde ont tous
ses amis disent le contraire
maintenant entre ce que ses amis disent
qu'ils ne connaissent très bien et entre
ce que l'opinion publique perçoit il ya
vraiment un grand décalage
ça voudrait dire qu emmanuel macron
pourrait
me fais l'avocat du diable
volontairement être victimes finalement
d'un système qui le dépasse ça va plus
vite que lui
il tombe dans les pièges sans les
maîtriser finalement nous n'aurons peut
dire non
on peut dire beaucoup de choses des
manuels macro sauf que c'est un imbécile
non c'est quelqu'un de très intelligent
en politique étrangère il a fait des
choses assez remarquable politique
intérieure c'est autre chose mais encore
une fois pour nférieure explique à faire
attention qui est pas de syndrome
jusqu'à c'est à dire que la personnalité
supplantent les compétences donc tout le
monde reconnaît que manuel macro est
très intelligent qu'il ait rompu tant
que parent dans n'importe quelle
situation ils maîtrisent mais il faut
aussi avoir une empathie avec les gens
parce que bon si vous voulez l'amour des
gens ça doit être comme un espèce de
parfums d'oxygène politique on doit
apporter la fait faire le bonheur des
gens et il faut qu'il ait plus
d'empathie et est donc là aujourd'hui on
lui demande pas de passer l'oral de
l'ena tous les jours on a compris qu'il
est intelligent
les gens attendent autre chose mais il
ya une réelle hystérie à une réelle
broca populaire et cette petite mesure
avec guy bricout qui a eu le bon sens de
proposer douze jours il fallait pas
voter il fallait dire bon ben ok on y va
et puis après les détails on verra plus
tard
comment vous voulez l'expliqué justement
c'est tout simplement un manque
d'empathie ou peut être une équipe qui
n'a pas l'habitude entre guillemets
laponie
vi vous savez être un spin doctor être
un entourage
c'est c'est savoir se cramer aussi ça
veut dire dire des choses que le
dirigeant n'a pas du tout envie
d'entendre
et dire des choses qui vend la politique
ça formidable révélateur de personnalité
donc il ya quelques fois où dit
attention stop là là ça ne va pas il ya
tel et tel point c'est pas possible que
vous voyez pas ça donc ça veut dire
risquer de se faire par la pop à
la fenêtre parce que vous voulez mais
mais avoir une générosité vraiment un
professionnalisme et dire quelque chose
qui ne va pas je ne sais pas d'ailleurs
il ya eu des entourages il ya un turn
over assez important je ne sais pas si
les gens sont champ suffisamment libre
dans la parole pour entourer le
président je ne sais pas est ce que
cette affaire peut aller à forte
peut-être d'erreur jusqu'à vraiment
fracassé la majorité on a vu le départ
de plusieurs députés la république en
marche est ce qu'ils ne pourraient
depuis y avoir cette solidarité envers
le gouvernement que la wii la veille au
soir à l'assemblée nationale en sentez
vraiment dans une une effervescence bon
des mots du maire
et on sent vraiment que et il va falloir
il va leur falloir ressouder les rangs
et c'est pas en faisant des crêpes au
chocolat qui m'ont offert donc là il ya
intérêt à la faire un peu mieux que ça
on n'a pas parlé des doigts flippant
file avant le central il a été au coeur
de cette réunion avec les députés
la république en marchant colère
apparemment la réunion s'est mieux
terminée qu'elle n'avait commencé c'est
l'homme de la situation edouard philippe
il a peut-être cette empathie que n'a
pas le chef de l'exécutif
emmanuel macron bat edouard philippe est
un bon premier ministre là il a il a
fait un point ce matin avec sa majorité
il a dit bon on va pas discuter sur la
responsabilité
bon c'est une boulette nous savons
aujourd'hui que ça va repartir vers le
sénat qui vont étoffer la proposition de
loi du député guy bricout quel député du
nord des bêtises de cambrai et donc ils
vont étoffer sa ils vont l'améliorer et
du coup on espère que ça va très très
vite revenir à l'assemblée nationale
parce que à mon avis il faut ré en face
de l'émotion il faut qu'ils aient de
l'action mais en face de l'émotion aussi
il faut qu'il y ait de la vitesse parce
que il va pas falloir duré trop
longtemps
il faut apporter de l'action et de la
rapidité puisque emmanuel macron m la
rapidité c'est le moment de le montrer
alors autre dossier épineux à
l'assemblée en ce moment un pas moins de
22 mille amendements sur cette réforme
des retraites van damme y est de la
france insoumise quel est le regard de
la communicante là dessus bon
naturellement que jean luc mélenchon
il essaye de se refaire une certaine
virginité parce que marine le pen lui
avait volé un peu le statut de premiers
opposants à emmanuel macron donc là
dessus il donne tout ce qu'il peut
donner
il est très cultivé il connaît
parfaitement les rouages de l'assemblée
donc lui le il entend déposer 19 me sur
22 il va il va utiliser la stratégie
avec méthode pour faire une obstruction
et vous savez qu'à l'assemblée nationale
il ya des petites commissions les
affaires sociales la défense etc
et là ils ont monté une commission
spéciale pour les retraites
donc chacun va travailler pour éplucher
ses vingt-deux mille amendements mais
nous savons que il ya un agenda
extrêmement serré là c'est pareil
c est ce que parfois ils ont pas un
problème de timing
quand il quand il lance une opération
ils ont lancé la retraite juste avant
noël résultats cafouillis vous avez vu
de fourmies donc deux mois de grève et
que c'était à chaque appel et là pendant
les vacances de février du 18 au 27
février
normalement on épluche tout ça je ne
suis pas sûr que on arrive à tenir les
délais ça m'étonnerait merci en tout cas
je vous en êtes fier d'avoir été avec
mon direct sur arte france docteur en
communication politique merci à hbo